[Music]
this is the ramsay
show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show it's
where america hangs out to have a
conversation about your life your work
your relationships your money i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague george
campbell and we're here together for you
this hour it's a free phone call to jump
in or it's all about you we want to help
you with breakthrough triple eight eight
two five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five how you doing pal
just glorious ken you're glorious it's
80 degrees and sunny in nashville yeah i
didn't ask you that i didn't ask you
that but thank you for the weather let's
be in a good mood oh does it you're in
good mood okay great how about we help
some people you ready for that i'm ready
he's glorious folks he's ready and
christian is ready he's on the line in
raleigh north carolina christian how can
we help
hey how you doing we are having a blast
and george is glorious
yeah well i'm 21 years old i'm about to
graduate college on the 7th of may
and i have some debt that i'm trying to
figure out the best way to pay it off
awesome well george can help let's do
this thing so how much debt are we
talking
uh i have 27 000 in student loans and
about 11 000 on a car payment okay
what's the car worth
uh the car's worth about 32
whoa
what kind of car is it
uh it's a 2017 gmc sierra yeah wow
21 year old driving that's a nice car
man so do you have a job right now
uh yes sir i work part-time and i'm a
full-time student
and i saved enough to put a hefty down
payment on it but
the job i have lined up after college
will be about
thirty five hundred dollars a month for
my income
is that take-home pay or is that gross
that's uh that's take-home okay
what kind of what kind of field is this
what
job uh computer science
awesome well that's got a lot of room
for growth if you're in that career path
like to hear that so
do you know what your plans are once you
graduate are you moving are you staying
put are you renting
staying at home for a few years so the
only expenses i have are the student
loans and the car payment okay what do
you mean by a few years what's the the
timeline for that based on
um
i don't really have a plan for that but
i'm planning on staying home
for at least two years
okay is that to pay off the debt faster
or
uh yes sir and also my job is only 15
minutes from my house
where i'm currently staying so
it's just easier commute
okay so you're going to be bringing home
about forty two thousand dollars a year
and what i want you to do when you
graduate and you step into that job is
to continue living like a broke college
kid
and get this debt out of your life as
soon as possible uh do you know what
your student loan payments are going to
be
the minimum is about 300 a month but
there's also a
benefit with
my job where they'll pay me 250
additional
to pay off the student loans every month
so i would only be paying 50 a month
yeah so my plan was with the snowball
would be just throw everything i have at
the car payment until that's done and
then throw everything at student loans
until that's done okay well here if i'm
in your shoes and that's how i answer
calls here i'm selling that car
okay i think it's just too much car for
you right now yeah and the fact that you
can get that much for it and you could
almost be out of debt if you sold that
thing right you said it would sell for
32.
yes sir and you have 11 on it which
leaves you
with just a nice chunk of change there
to get rid of those student loans which
you could then do with what six months
maybe
yes sir what kind of transportation
would you need if you sell that car um
oh that's the that's the only form of
vehicle i have so i would just have to
get something else
all right so you you would have how much
georgia was left over you said you'd
sell for 32 you owe 11. that would leave
you with 21.
and so i'm gonna buy five thousand
dollars five six thousand dollar beater
car for now yeah this is not forever no
but for right now as a 21 year old
you'll be okay
and uh you do that and you'll have six
thousand left over yeah uh 21 so
subtract the five you'd pay on the car
that still leaves you about 16 000 to
throw at the student loans oh man which
takes you down to 11 on the student
loans that's great and you if you could
throw you know a thousand bucks a month
two thousand bucks a month you're living
at home right you have no expenses
yes sir
i like this plan and my plan would be to
move out
way faster than two years
when those loans are done and you got an
emergency fund in place i'm gonna fly
the coop and i'm gonna get my own place
and rent and then begin the work of you
know saving up for a down payment if
that's what you want to do
okay so i mean right now i have an
emergency fund of about two grand from
part-time work
okay
so i'm just so do i need to save any
more or should i just throw everything i
have at the loans
loans paid off and then start saving i
would cut that down to a thousand so i
take the thousand that's gonna help get
rid of those loans even faster
on top of whatever you have after buying
a new beater car and that's gonna speed
up the process even faster and once you
do that we're not talking two years
until you have a big savings account
we're talking
eight months maybe
yeah
so put this plant on paper
yes
man you can make that kind of money on
that car right now as a guy who's just
starting out his career trust me you're
gonna be driving nicer cars later in
life but right now if you continue to
live like a broke college student you
will be unbelievably wealthy yeah and by
the way i want to point out a
relationship aspect here 21 year old you
know he's graduating the ladies don't
care about the car as much as you think
they do now my wife stacey and i are
about ready to celebrate to 24 years of
marriage and when we started dating i
was driving a mazda 626 with 200 and who
knows how many miles on it 200 000 and
it was such a piece of crap that i would
to make her laugh on dates i would pull
the key out of the ignition while i was
driving and show her the keys was she
impressed no oh but she laughed that's
the point is she she she didn't care
yeah she didn't care about the car i
drove the car i had in high school i
drove for a decade yeah it wasn't long
ago that i finally you won big with the
ladies too so oh yeah you know
they don't call me george's lady killer
camel for nothing oh there it is no i
was invisible to girls in high school
yeah it panned out but yeah it worked
out great so the point is is on this
deal it's like when you can sell the car
certainly in times like this because
this is applicable to a lot of people
listening and watching right now hot car
market hot car market if you can get rid
of that debt by selling it
uh it's a temporary move but i'm telling
you i'm in the market right now i've
been telling you this
uh for my kid yeah and i'm not gonna
sink a lot of money into it because he
didn't take me up on the challenge
however much you make i'll match
so now i'm going i'm going to get him
something that's serviceable
but if he if he runs it into a tree or a
guardrail you know what i mean i'm not
going to be like all but a lot of
parents they go well junior needs to
drive a safe reliable car so they go buy
junior 35 000 brand new car right
finance yeah let me tell you what's
ludicrous we did what's safe and
reliable something that cost about four
or five grand that you know it's an old
toyota honda something like that you
know what i mean parts aren't that
expensive you take good care of it who
cares what it looks like it's safe and
reliable you know the truth is i think a
lot of parents their reputation's on the
line when junior's driving the beater
car around oh and they want to look good
yeah and let me tell you something
george you're absolutely right parents
stop making your kid's car one of your
status symbols college kids don't need
to be driving 30 40 000 cars no that's
not our opinion that's facts well they
want to go out and make the money then
go for it junior i like that all right
tell you what else i like we're just
getting started
more of your calls right around the
corner it's a free call triple eight
eight two five
five two two five this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move
and you don't have to be in the dark
here over 31 000 businesses including my
team at ramsey know their numbers
because they use netsuite by oracle the
number one cloud financial system
netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
is a game changer so head on over to
netsuite.com ramsey to get a product
tour today that's netsuite.com
ramsey
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show where we
help you win with your money your work
and your relationships george campbell
joining me i'm kid coleman ramsey
personalities as we take your calls this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five the phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
all right speaking of money george and
and budgets and boy you're the guy
uh
it's very kind saw a story on yahoo
about jessica simpson
joking that she's on a budget what is
this all about i'm just as confused as
you can but it's a fun little piece here
jessica simpson jokes that she's on a
budget after her credit card got denied
at a taco bell you can't make this stuff
that's awkward this is there's a lot
going on here like are you surprised
that she went to taco bell there's
there's a lot of things i'm surprised
about here yeah she strikes me as a
wendy's uh fan really yeah i don't know
why okay i don't see jessica simpson in
taco bell yeah you know like what is she
getting there if you go into a taco bell
drive-through it is the most beautiful
melting pot of economics i mean there oh
is that right there's people in you know
sports cars wealthy folks okay it does
know this
taco bell you know does not discriminate
oh everyone loves them some late night
tacos and so does jessica simpson so
there she is the article opens jessica
simpson has some beef with taco bell
the artist 41 joked about having her
credit card declined at the popular fast
food chain while focusing her finances
on her ever-growing businesses as she
appeared this week on the reel quote i
have no working credit card simpson said
it's okay i'll pay in cash i went to
taco bell the other day and my card got
denied i'm on a budget ladies
that's a great quote right there she
added that she's draining my bank
account into growing her eponymous
billion dollar fashion brand of which
she and her mother tina regained control
of in october the multi-hyphenate even
considered borrowing against her home
for the big business move oh boy okay
that's confusing you're on a budget but
you're also going further into debt yeah
i don't know if she is on a budget but i
know this george we all got to be on a
budget when you don't have a reality tv
show very there's some confusing things
here she's got the cash to pay for taco
bell but the car is getting declined
yeah because she's got no credit be left
because she's spent it all on her she's
maxed it out her company she's maxed it
that's it thank you for using see i
don't even know the right words to use
we'll get there
but it's an interesting thing when you
look at you know celebrities and
finances because a lot of people go well
you know celebrities they're making so
much money they have it easy but a lot
of people who make really good money can
still be broke
it's fascinating how that works yeah so
i applaud jessica if she truly is on a
budget i think it's great and jessica if
you're listening uh my wife loved your
biography and we encourage you to check
out every dollar
that's what would you say if you were
gonna coach jessica simpson because a
lot of wealthy people blow their money
they don't do well would you have taco
bell in the budget
i think so you would yeah i mean
personally you know you allow for fast
food is a part of a budget i've gotta
watch my physique ken personally as you
do too yeah you know at your age it
matters even
it matters even more wow but no this is
good i like this you know we talk about
how if you're trying to get out of debt
we don't want you to see the inside of a
restaurant and so that means you're not
eating out that's what i'm
and you're saying it's okay well i think
once you're out of debt absolutely let's
throw you know throw it in the budget
now i don't want you eating out every
single day mostly because it's bad for
your health on top of your budget yeah
uh but a little a little taco bell never
hurt anyone
and plus it's the cheapest way to buy
gas these days
taco bell dollar menu here you go ken
there's my dad joke for the day oh man
there's so many ways i could go with
that it's only a dollar nineteen to get
gas at taco bell dollar 19. yeah i'll
tell you what i don't know that if we
can prove that it's good for anybody
though no but i do want all celebrities
and all normal americans to be on a
budget and to stay away from debt so
jessica don't borrow against your home
don't max out your credit cards you are
running this fashion empire
use this revenue wisely we tell people
with entree leadership to run their
businesses completely debt-free yeah and
people say you can't do that ken but we
meet them every single year at our
entree leadership events and they're
amazing business owners small business
owners who are running their businesses
completely debt-free using cash
love to see it very interesting stuff
there you go would have loved to see
what that order was i'm just glad
yahoo's still around
it's amazing when you said that it was
like nostalgic to me yeah a lot going on
in my head i got jingles running through
my head the yahoo commercials talk about
i got the whole thing i'm trying to
refrain from friday yeah because i don't
want james rolling his eyes at me all
right to the phones we go stace is
joining us
from kansas city missouri states how can
we help
hello hello hi
hi
you're on the ramsey show what's up you
made it
yay hurry i finally did hey um
you guys you do such great work i
can't even believe i'm on the phone with
you guys
um
so
um i
i'm in a bit of a mess um what's the
mess just tell us
huh it's hard to admit okay it's really
hard to admit no judgment or shame here
i
i have a credit card
a couple credit cards and um
before i
married my husband i
racked up some debt and
i haven't been able to pay them off
um
2019 i had my son
and um i didn't want to go back to work
so i i'm
raising my kids i'm a stay-at-home mom
and i don't have an income and
at least the one card knows this
that i mean i don't i'm not working
um
and i'm being sued by them
what what company
uh
well
uh
i i'm gonna butcher this guys i
gramaci and meyer
pc
what's the credit card company
um
capital one cabela's
we just took a call recently ken and it
was capital one apparently they're
notorious for suing people so just one
more reason to stay away from credit
cards but um
yeah a letter from a law firm there we
go ah there we go i'm writing slogans
while george is helping people so stace
what how much credit card debt is this
um it is
hundred eighty eight dollars and eight
okay and what's your communication been
with them
um i called them i told them i wouldn't
have any money until
taxes came and then
we just didn't have it i mean we were
you know we were trying to take care of
stuff i paid off my car
you know so so how much debt do you have
outside of this credit card
uh
well
this credit card which is 2214.73
is the other one and then um
and you're not making payments on that
one either
no
we just don't have it so when you say we
don't have it you said you don't have an
income are you talking about your
husband no
yeah
none of us do really what's his income
he makes
under 50 000 a year okay is he willing
to work
another job
well it's a little complicated
um i think
i think he is
but um he works
let me rephrase that stacey he needs to
get another job you guys don't feel the
sense of urgency that i'm feeling for
you which is you're on fire right now we
have to get these lawsuits out of our
life we have to get control and you've
got to pay the credit card
you've got to pay the bill and so
with this lawsuit i don't know what's
going to happen
you might be able to settle but that
would still mean you need an amount in
the bank that you are able to pay
because they're going to say well yeah
you don't have an income but you all
have an income as a family and so they
can garnish his wages
they can do a lot of things
and so you need to get a little fire in
your belly to get this thing out of your
life and it's the same plan that
everyone else uses it's the debt
snowball it's getting your baby step one
starter emergency fund in place and
starting to attack this so i'm gonna
work with them to go hey what am i
willing to settle for i don't wanna take
this to the court what are you willing
to do i don't have much to my name i can
scrounge up a thousand dollars will you
take that and if they say yes you do it
let's not fight over this you went into
this debt we got to take some
responsibility here and stay somebody
tell you this right now your husband
needs to be working every night of the
week and then maybe he watches the kids
on the weekends and you're working we
are together going to go work and 2 000
to pay this office not that much money
if you both are working this is a great
economy to go make some money and
getting more income and then getting
disciplined is how you get out of this
mess no excuses this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you that's why you need to get in touch
with churchill mortgage to make sure you
do this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free homeownership and churchill is
here to help go to their site
churchhillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show i'm kid coleman
joined by george campbell this hour and
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage is brittany brittany
welcome hi how are you i'm excited to be
here all right so we're gonna do a
debt-free scream is that what's going on
here yes all right and where are you
from brittany i'm from smyrna georgia
smyrna georgia i know where smyrna
georgia is all right fantastic all right
let's get the details how much debt did
you pay off 32 000
okay and how long took me about 21
months 21 months what was your range of
income
um started around 35 and then by the
time everything was paid off about 46.
oh very nice what do you do
i'm an implementations manager for a
tech company nice that sounds very smart
yes like i feel i feel like britney has
got it together a lot of syllables in
there implementation manager yeah yeah i
like that sure nice so uh what was the
debt
um a car loan credit cards and a little
bit of medical debt oh really okay
thank you george what was the car
um i had a mazda cx-5 uh-huh all right
how does that feel to have that one out
of the way it's huge it was actually the
last kind of thing that i did to pay off
my debt you know i thought that i was
going to be paying it off for another
year or two i didn't really want to let
go of that car that i still owed you
know money on but when i looked at the
numbers and i knew the used car market
right now is kind of crazy so
when we were just talking about it one
day i finally looked up and see to see
what it would appraise for and it when i
saw the numbers and knew that i could
get rid of my car but also get rid of my
car payment and also leave with a check
to pay off the rest of my debt it was
like a no-brainer easy decision
i love that so that was the acceleration
at the end yes to help you finish this
out yeah selling the car wow see i love
that a lot of people aren't willing to
do that and you did it and boy that
makes a big difference quickly so what
happened 21 months ago
how did you how did you get into this
journey this debt-free journey yeah so
i'm
just like you guys always say i was a
financial peace baby so i grew up in
church i always heard about dave ramsey
my parents are here they did financial
peace when i was younger and it's funny
i always remember like the first class
that they took
they made us start ordering just water
when we went out to eat and i really
hated that so
that's kind of how dave ramsey's been in
my mind
over these years terrible parenting
but just growing up i always knew about
it uh when i went to college i graduated
and moved home my parents so graciously
let me live at home without any you know
rent or anything so i didn't have any
bills
but also for first full-time income that
i wasn't used to having so really just
lived above my means and racked up all
the credit card debt that i could
i also decided that it was time for me
to get my own car
instead of you know having one without a
car payment i thought it was smart to
you know really be an adult and get my
own car payment so got myself car
payment and then also decided i wanted
to move out on my own
so got my own apartment of course had to
furnish the apartment all that
but just continued to still live above
my means and kind of got
over my head in credit card bills um and
then when my credit card started maxing
out i was like
i've really got a problem
when i sat down and totaled it and i saw
it was
almost as much as i made in a year i
really knew that it was time to to do
something so i actually went to
the bank and tried to get a loan like a
lot of people do
to consolidate and i i didn't get
accepted for it and i just broke down
crying right there in the um in the
teller's cubicle and i felt really bad
but i was just like i don't i don't know
what to do i've lost hope um and she
gave me all the
pamphlets and everything that banks do
you know credit repair and all that but
she she looked at me and she was like
i don't have anything for this but we
went me and my husband went through dave
ramsey's financial peace university and
it really changed our life changed our
marriage and i'm like yeah i know about
dave ramsey like you know
just like not something i wanted to do
but she didn't know but she was really
planting a seed um and me and i didn't
realize that until later in life
actually a few months later i met my
boyfriend wit and we we
had the financial conversation about you
know
you can't really hide you know the
struggle that i was going through so we
we talked about it and he was like
i don't know if you've ever heard of
this guy um dave ramsey i was like yeah
okay god i see you like you bring a cue
boy in my life and of course i'm like
all in for it now you know i've heard it
for a million times as you dave ramsey
so
during quarantine when things were shut
down we watched all the
all the lessons together and then um
back in january we started an in-person
class when things started kind of
opening up again so wow
so you couldn't turn a corner without
hearing about this guy dave ramsey fine
fine god i'll do it yeah and it just
worked yep you got on the plane you
decided to live on less than you make
get a hold of your life
and here you are today on the dead free
stage yep you're a hero we're so proud
of you thank you that is awesome so what
was the hardest part in the journey for
you
um
i think just
for me it was most important to just
remember my why because there was times
where i was you know i did every side
hustle imaginable i had my normal
nine-to-five job and then i was out
doing door dash i walked a lot of dogs
did a lot of dog sitting so it was just
a lot of time that i didn't get to go
spend with my friends or do stuff that i
wanted to do and it was really hard but
in the back of my mind i knew it was a
temporary sacrifice to be able to live
you know comfortably for the rest of my
life and i just always had to go back to
my why
um when it did get hard there was a lot
of breakdowns and whit so gracefully
reminded me he's like just remember you
know this is only temporary you're gonna
you're gonna thank yourself for really
pushing through um
wow
you had some cheerleaders in your corner
which is awesome i mean from the banker
to your boyfriend to your parents were
there any detractors
uh
no i don't think so okay i think she was
too busy to have any detroit i was
really busy you weren't really busy you
hear the haters you were busy door
dashing right i was like i know you some
people think i'm crazy especially you
know now that i don't have i still don't
have a car i got rid of that in january
when i never got a new car not yet right
now i'm saving up cash for one so how
are you getting around just lyft and
getting rides from people no kidding
well i do a lot of walking because where
i live in smyrna it's you know yeah good
for you look at that see that's enough
that right there bashes the myth that
you gotta have a car to function right
now some people do her life allows her
to do that but it can be possible oh
yeah because you're budgeting for the
lift and all that stuff right and i'm
actually spending less than i did with
my car payment and with insurance and
with gas you know it came at the perfect
time in january when gas prices i like
that started skyrocketing so you'll save
up real fast now you don't have a
payment in the world nope wow so i'm
able to save a lot for uh
get a car in the next couple months so
what are you dreaming about now you're a
young lady your life's in front of you
you're debt-free how does that change
your perspective about the future it's
just awesome because now i feel like i
can actually save for my future and for
my family one day and my kids and i can
really give them the life that you know
they want so i'm excited to see do some
traveling um we'll see everything's just
it's so much easier now you know like i
said i don't have any payments so i'm
able to save you know a lot of money and
start investing so i'm excited you and i
were talking about this during the
commercial break she she's free oh yeah
not just free from debt she's free to
make a lot of different decisions
because she's not shackled by debt she's
got options now she's not backed into a
corner going well i got these payments
so what are you gonna do
you decided to take control instead of
waiting for someone else to fix your
life exactly and that's what this show
is all about i love that just gotta do
it fans start today what do you tell
people someone your age is listening
right now watching what is the key to
getting out of debt
just know that there's hope and i think
when you're looking at any sort of goal
always look at what you want your life
to look like and for me it was just
remembering my why you know i can't wait
to live
debt free and be able to give back and
build my wealth and you know set myself
up for retirement one day but always
just looking
at what you want in life and then
working backwards and thankfully dave
gives you that plan the baby steps um to
kind of get to that goal so it was easy
for me to follow that plan because i
knew at the end it would be so
worth it and that this the temporary
sacrifice is like is it's a lot shorter
than you think because i thought i was
still going to be paying for three four
years but really it only took me a
little less than two because i got that
fire under me um i was just hustling so
i love that yeah wow well brittany you
inspire us you're inspired a lot of
young people by telling your story so we
thank you for that we want to show our
uh appreciation to you by giving you two
books one dave's book total money
makeover for you to give to somebody
else and kind of pass that legacy on and
then the next step for you is baby steps
millionaire you're on your way you're
going to be a millionaire young lady and
that is very very exciting so we're
going to give you that book as well all
right the time has come brittany are you
ready i'm ready all right she's going to
do her debt free scream it's britney
from smyrna georgia she paid off 32
thousand in 21 months making 35 000 all
the way up to 46 000
brittany let's go let's hear your debt
free screen three two one
i'm done free
[Music]
there it is
very nice
oh wow
for our listening audience i wish you
could just see her face and overcome
with emotion as she
screams cathartic free and she's crossed
the finish line proud mom and dad out
there and don't forget boyfriend of the
year nominee wit for all the support
the ramsay show continues right after
this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ramsay show continues
from our world headquarters in the
nashville area i'm kim coleman joined by
george campbell we're here for you this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five george it's hard to believe
we're less than a week away for uh from
our next live event in las vegas it is
our building wealth live event the event
is next thursday it's going to be really
really fun in vegas or surrounding areas
if you don't have your tickets yet make
sure to go and reserve your spot now
just a couple of clicks of a button will
put you on your way to doing better with
investments and savings we're going to
really talk about how to build real
wealth no matter where you are with
money today it is possible we're going
to tackle the latest get rich quick
trends dive deep into investing saving
and planning for retirement
and it's not complicated it's actually
simple we're giving you a clear path on
how to do all that and uh we know that
you'll win big dave ramsey rachel cruz
george campbell dr john deloney and i
are all together
uh at the event on the stage george is
going to wear a mini
uh elvis costume we did get that
approved i love that it's a mini one
well you're a small guy not a full-size
one but no that would look silly uh so
we're looking forward to that uh we're
not sure about the peanut butter banana
sandwiches we'll see about that so if
you're near las vegas in las vegas don't
miss out thursday may the 5th tickets
are just 25 each and you can get a four
pack of tickets for only 60 dollars
bring your friends it's gonna be great
ramsay
com solutions.com events ramsay
solutions dot com
slash
events see you there vegas
all right let's go back to the phones
martin is joining us now in cleveland
ohio home of the cleveland browns oh yes
martin how can we help
hey guys how you guys doing good what's
going on
all right so my wife and i are having a
disagreement um kind of
so a short back story we see uh we went
to on vacation north carolina she's been
there her whole life and i i went there
one time with her and it's obviously a
gorgeous state uh right next to
tennessee
and uh
you know we talked about moving there at
one point i'm 25 years old she's 21. uh
we just got married less than a year ago
all right congrats all all of our family
is up here in cleveland like we have
eight sets of parents
everyone no one's in north carolina
um so i was thinking
we're on track to pay off our debts and
uh you know have a down payment here in
a couple years but i'm thinking you know
that's when we decide when do we play
down payment on a house near cleveland
near everyone um or should we move out
of state
the question is like my argument is
uh we have a big support system here
for you know when we have a kid
which i feel like that would be very
like useful you know uh babysitting and
whatnot
but you know she really i really want
her to be happy and i really like the
state too
i'm a truck driver so driving not in the
winter would be great
because cleveland winters are pretty
brutal
okay so i i hear of the formation of a
question but i don't hear a specific
question so before we get to that did
you say you had eight sets of parents
did i hear that
yeah yeah so because every single one of
our parents got divorced and remarried
so we have eight pairs oh okay gotcha
all right needed clarity on that that is
a lot of babysitting help i got to tell
you as a guy with three kids that's a
real bonus i'm not gonna let that one
slide by all right so what is the real
question martin hit us
i guess the question is like what what
kind of questions would you ask
yourselves you know i can't even pick
out a drink at the gas station let alone
decide whether or not i should move your
different state well there's your first
problem paralyzed by indecision yeah so
you so here's the deal you need to
number one you need to
uh own the fact that you have a problem
making decisions and try to get behind
what's really but what's going on there
um
but let's start with as a guy who's been
married almost 24 years let's start with
the all-important question what does
your wife want to do she want to go to
north carolina or does she want to stay
in cleveland ohio
she thinks she wants to move to north
carolina okay so um what i would start
with is you guys need to go take a trip
to an area that she maybe maybe there's
three areas in north carolina i'm making
this up but i would take a nice little
weekend the two of you away and i would
go kind of just hang out see some
neighborhoods get an idea of what's
going on and let's get ourselves in that
environment and see how she really
responds and then you mr indecision guy
uh you need to be honest about what
you're afraid of right it's okay to just
say wow i'm worried about this and i'm
nervous about this george you uh tend to
be very neurotic what would you say that
is very true thank you for bringing that
up ken i'm working through it yeah uh
here's where i go with this i have
i don't live near my family anymore i
moved when i was 20. from boston and now
i'm in the south here my wife's family
they just moved down to florida so we're
not close to family we don't have kids
yet so similar to their situation
they're newlyweds so i'm not gonna make
a decision based on this alone
this is not a deal breaker for me to be
away from family i'm gonna we see our
families you know two three four times a
year yeah and it's not that big of a
deal so i wouldn't base it on free
babysitting let's stay in cleveland ohio
forever because of this
so
by the way the downside of all those
parents
it makes me think of a movie for
christmases oh that's a lot going on at
holiday time you know great movie but
yeah that's exhausting i'm exhausted
thinking about how you handle the
holidays martin which one excites you
more the idea of moving north carolina
as you guys talk about this do you start
to kind of your eyes light up a little
bit so
i i'm a very adventurous person i love
the idea of being by the ocean and north
carolina is so gorgeous like i'm a truck
driver at night i hate winters in
cleveland truck driving it's a nightmare
but i'm also very practical person and i
like to like lay out every little number
i can before i make a decision and
there's really no see see what you just
did there martin
you see what you see what's going on
george asked you a point blank question
and your heart let off
your heart answered it i want to be near
the beach i like the warm weather
uh i drive a truck i don't want to drive
in the winter you said all this earlier
so your heart is saying north carolina
but then you go then your head starts to
go
slow down skippy we have a lot of things
that could go wrong and your head starts
getting involved you can convince
yourself either way and truthfully
neither either one you'd have a fine
life
now the question is what can you do
without regret that's not going to keep
you up at night and the truth is you can
always go back home and visit the truth
is you can afford a babysitter when you
need to find someone to watch the kids
yeah and so if you look at the solutions
you go okay well if that was our deal
breaker i guess uh it's really not yeah
i got to tell you martin this is a good
old-fashioned pros and cons you and your
wife separate right uh and and she
writes her pros and cons for going uh to
north carolina and you do yours then you
guys meet in the middle of a nice little
candlelight dinner maybe uh compare
notes and then go to carolina one time
and you know i think it's going to be
obvious i think it's already obvious i'm
moving if i'm in their shoes just based
on what i know well i don't want to
knock anybody at cleveland ohio here
comes the hate mail but if it's between
cleveland ohio and charlotte north
carolina area it's not even up for vote
for me that's just me all right just me
thank you for that ken yeah saying well
you gotta we're trying to head
trying to spread hate and dissension as
dave always says
oh
wow uh you know you make a very
interesting point though that's rare
sorry
let's talk about the financial questions
yeah because we talked a lot about those
were more personal the emotions and
reasoning we talked a lot about that
what would you say to a young couple on
the financial side of things
what would they need to look at on a
move from one region to another i think
there's no urgency to this they're
newlyweds so i think it's okay to just
get to know each other let's pay off
this debt let's get an emergency fund in
place and let's reassess we're going to
be at a very different place emotionally
once we've been married for a year two
years the debts out of our life we've
got an emergency fund now we can be
clear-headed about every single decision
we're not worried about how we're gonna
pay for the move we're not as worried
about what's gonna happen with our our
jobs over there we can just do this with
a lot more clarity and so i'm
encouraging them to go hey pause what is
the urgency behind this do we need to
make this decision today or can we park
it and go hey let's focus on this debt
and let's circle back to this
conversation a year from now and see
where we're at yeah i like that because
the bottom line is that area or any
other area of the country still going to
be there
and and so at that point we can decide
we want to clean up our financial mess
because again it just gives us more
options you know it changes where we
might be able to live in a certain area
uh the other thing that i don't think
people think through a lot is cost of
living oh yeah you know there is
cleveland to charlotte there could be a
jump there it might be yeah i don't know
uh but you got to look at all of that
and uh i just i don't i i can't
overestimate
the importance of going and visiting
putting yourself in that place because
the fear that that holds a lot of people
up the most is the fear of the unknown
yeah and regret so go figure out what
you don't know go get an answer and now
we can make a decision based on real
information not a vacuum of fear and
doubt that's running around in our minds
a lot of wisdom there all right good
hour george
hey
this is your show folks it is the ramsey
show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we talk about your life your money
your work and your relationships i'm ken
coleman joined by george campbell this
hour triple eight eight two five five
two two five is the phone number it's
toll free triple eight eight two five
five
two two five you ready to roll so ready
we're feeling good come on man calls are
on the board game on let's go rachel
joins us in bloomington indiana rachel
how can we help
hey i'm so glad to get you guys advice
on this
great um so my husband and i have been
saving um for our
home for like 15 years for a house in
the country
um and we found something that has a
barn and you know opportunity for
animals and things like that for our
kids which is what we want
the problem is as we are we are facing a
lot of fears and concerns about it and
we don't know if these are legitimate
fears because it's not a good financial
decision or if this is just like us
stepping out of our comfort zone because
we really haven't had to do that um this
this far in our marriage
so we need help deciphering
whether those are legitimate fears okay
great do you mind outlining very
specifically what the top fears are
um i think the top fear is that it will
be a financial burden instead of a
blessing for us
okay what else
um
we're worried that we'll regret it after
we do it um
anything else enough
we won't have enough money to
um
do things other than live in our home
like go on vacation
which leads me to believe george these
may be uh fears that protect not fears
that hold back we'll see break it down
because fear is either here's what's
going on rachel i'm setting setting you
up because because these are financial
uh in in you and sharing these
and so here's what we know about fear
so fear can protect us right if we edge
up to the edge of a cliff right and we
start to feel a pang of fear fears
protecting us like slow down because you
could fall over to your impending death
right but sometimes fear can hold us
back right it's kind of the old the idea
of the elephant that's terrified of the
mouse you know
and and so we need to figure that out
george what do you think there with
those fears well my question is you've
been saving for 15 years how much money
do you have saved
um okay so that we have um we're gonna
put 200 000 out of savings down on the
home okay and then we are expecting we
have our house paid off
and we're hoping to get 200
conservatively we will get 200 000 for
our home so we can put four hundred
thousand dollars down on on down on how
much
um it's 4.85 total
so you'd have an 85 000 mortgage
it's a mouse you're an elephant what's
your income i listen
okay so listen i stay at home my husband
works
um and he makes a net of 95 000 a year
okay and so the big fear like we
understand we can't afford the house but
the big concern and the big fear is that
um the taxes are and insurance are going
to be pretty high like a lot higher than
what we're used to do you know that for
a fact do you know the exact number
uh we can we have a real good idea
okay are you talking property taxes
yes property taxes in bloomington
yep wow
i'm a little shocked by a here in
tennessee ken i'll tell you that well no
property taxes are pretty stiff here
rachel when it comes to mortgages let me
just tell you our parameters and i think
this will give you peace because it did
for me uh when we were paying off our
house we tell people to get a 15-year
fixed-rate mortgage the only one i'd
ever tell you to get where the the
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay that includes your
principal interest taxes insurance all
in less than 25 of take-home pay
and you're putting way more than 10 or
20 down so i'm not worried about that
part so now let's look at the real
numbers you have an 85 000 mortgage we
have these high property taxes have you
crunched the numbers to see how much of
that of your take-home pay it's going to
eat up
it's going to take it's it's good i
think it's just under 25 percent okay
okay but that so after the
after our house is completely paid off
with taxes and insurance we're still
gonna it's still gonna be one thousand
one hundred dollars just for taxes and
insurance okay that's okay
i'm not as worried about that so here's
what i'm seeing though if you look at
those numbers i want you to look at the
facts to give you some peace here and go
okay this is not 70 of our take-home pay
being eaten up by mortgage and taxes we
have 75 percent of our take-home pay to
still go accomplish all of our other
goals take care of our family go on
vacations we can still have a life
that's why we tell people to stick with
these conservative parameters because i
want you to still have a life
and that's what you're worried about are
we going to be able to do all these
other things if we have if we get into
this house and you told me it's been
your dream for 15 years
yes and so to me there's some other
fears there other than financially
you're not broke you're not going to be
broke no you're going to pay this thing
off uh within what maybe two years
yeah i think it's just that's and that's
the thing we couldn't decipher whether
it was like this we just haven't had a
step out of our box
is it just fear of stepping
rachel let me tell you what i heard
earlier you george walked you through
and you had you told him he said well
it's it's less than 25 percent he said
that's what we recommend it's very
conservative and your immediate response
was yeah but it's gonna be eleven
hundred dollars in taxes and that's a
new number for you and it seems
exorbitantly high because
based on your previous context it is
so i remember the first time my wife and
i bought a house it was 195 000 and i
thought i had i thought that i'd
mortgaged my future away and it was you
know i was making good but i mean i
never owned a house yeah so 195 000 is
like
you know what i mean and we were living
dave's principles my wife worked for
dave at the time i did not so i think
it's context
and george has just walked you through
and that you're okay and can i just also
say something i hope encourages you
what got you here is going to get you
there wherever there is you're going to
pay this house off you guys are going to
be baby steps millionaires true or false
i'd like to say true
no you will be you will be you're doing
it the right way you're going to pay off
that 80.
no no dad no okay yeah
and so
when you don't have any payments you
have freedom and so with that freedom
comes peace and so i want you to take a
look most people that call into the show
ken they have been wanting a house for
14 seconds they have no money to put
down and they do it anyways right
they've saved 200 000 over would you say
14 years 15 years 15 years it's time to
pull the trigger on this this is
i mean i don't even know how you've been
focused for 15 years i would have given
up
yes listen rachel that's what we're
doing we're bragging on you and your
husband
incredible discipline to have amassed
what you have amassed you guys are gonna
be great go get that place and it's
gonna be paid for in a few years and
then you'll have property taxes but
you'll still be unbelievably wealthy if
you just have property taxes and
insurance to pay for and as a home
warming gift george is going to send you
a baby llama so is that part of the plan
well i would send a baby camel before a
llama can you know i'm team campbell to
be on theme yeah i don't know who's
doing pr for llamas but they've done a
great job it's time for camels to step
up yeah well i got a 13 year old girl
and any parent or 13 year old girl gets
that i don't know where these animals
came from with their popularity but it
is what a diatribe we just went
left turn there well adhd is a real
thing george and uh the next medication
point is later this hour so hey don't
move more of the ramsey show coming
right up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsay show thrilled to have you
with us
helping you win with your money winning
your work winning your relationships i'm
ken coleman joined by george campbell
the phone number is free to call in for
some breakthrough triple eight eight two
five
five two two five triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to
minneapolis where savvy joins us on the
line savvy how can we help
hi guys thank you so much for taking my
call of course what's happening today
all right let me give you some
background information okay so in two
weeks i'm graduating with my undergrad
degree nice
yes and i'm also part of an accelerated
master's program through this school
that i'm about a quarter way through my
master's in counseling
so
then in june i'm getting married
and
we combined we'll have around 100k in
student loan debt
um
but i also got a job on monday and my
fiance is currently working he makes
about 53k a year and i'll be making
around 50k a year so
total will have around 103 000 per year
as our salary
and we're completely down to start the
baby steps
but
we want to cashflow my masters so that
we don't have any more student loan debt
and
we are just wondering if
it would be wise to
treat the master's fund as
a baby step before we start the baby
steps save up all the cash in around six
or seven months to just fully fund that
and how much higher baby stuff okay how
much it would be the what what's left in
the master's fund to be able to pay that
um it would be around so we would have
about 20k total my grandparents gifts
every grandchild during college
graduation nine grand to use for
whatever so we're going to put that
towards the masters as well so we have
around
11 or
yeah 11 or 12. so you'd have to come up
with 11
to uh
to cash flow your way through
yeah um
i'm not suggesting you do this i'm just
asking
if you were to press pause
on the master's degree because you're
already employed i'm assuming are you
employed in the area that you want to be
in with this masters in counseling or is
it completely
separate so my master's is online
and i my job i begin after married and
it is where my fiance is living in
colorado right now right but is it is it
in the field of counseling your job
um no it's an hr okay so it's totally
unrelated
um
and you do it all online
so
pausing is not something you're
interested in doing because it's going
to take you a while
i can see that to pay off the you know
the 103 even with that great income yeah
um yeah well george i mean i absolutely
believe we she can cash flow your
thoughts on this yeah i mean we want to
avoid debt no more at all costs and so
if that means cash flowing while we pay
minimum payments on the rest of our debt
that's okay that's you're investing in
savvy right now and we'll get to that
debt when you graduate and you've got
that new job we're going to start
attacking this debt with a vengeance so
i'm okay with that i love the idea of
you cash flowing this 11. the question
is how fast can we do it and can we
accelerate that even faster yes are you
going to be able to save 11 in time
before the master's program starts
so i'm going so i'm in the fall i'll be
enrolling in my next classes and we're
going to use the nine grand um each
semester is around five grand so we're
gonna use five of the nine to pay for
that continue saving for the next
semester we should be able to get that
much money by then and then
something i forgot to mention is with my
job that i just got is they will
reimburse you five grand a year for
educational reimbursement wow
i can also i could
really
get the majority of the remainder paid
for by my job but they only pay like in
january and i'd be enrolling in
august
or whatever so we'd have to pay forward
before that so if the nine grand would
cover what how many which months
um the nine grand would cover the fall
semester
and then um a little over half of the
next semester after that and then i
would
get reimbursed by my work that great
well that brings your cost down to what
six grand
yep something like that so now the
question is how quickly can i save up
six grand
making 50k a year
yeah plus side hustles i mean selling
stuff uh every everything because what
george is leading you to here is is that
the quicker we can fund the masters the
quicker we start on the baby steps
exactly so if you've got that money set
aside for the masters you know it's
going to be paid for now we can start
attacking the debt while we're still in
the master's program
yeah and how how quickly is this masters
gonna happen
um so we'll have around three grand take
home each month after paying all of our
bills um
so it should be around two months if we
were really grinding with like the baby
step mindset towards saving up for the
master's money okay um
yes but i think the question george is
asking is how long before you finish the
master the accelerated program yeah when
so i have around two and a half years
left okay
all right and what do you want to do
with that masters
so i will be in the lpc after i pass my
exam after that master's so i just want
to be a mental health counselor in
um really any setting i'm down to try um
awesome but yeah so i'm looking forward
to that too yeah well thank you so much
for the call yeah absolutely it sounds
like this thing's uh you've got the plan
let's just stay on the course yeah avoid
debt and we'll get this debt knocked out
yeah i love the intensity advice let's
get on those baby steps fast um and she
does very little to fund they can do
this oh yeah multiple jobs i mean this
is get after it stuff let's go to barry
in sacramento california barry how can
we help
hey guys thank you for having me on sure
um i've got a life
changing opportunity coming up i've got
settlement money that i never expected
coming in and i
have no idea what to do with it i've
seen a lot of money go with a lot of
zeros
behind it and turn quickly into zeros in
front of that so i am
new i just want to know what you guys
might have um an opinion on on what i
should do with this money what kind of
settlement was this
um this is a big settlement i lost
everything that i've ever owned and this
is kind of paying me back for that
so not health related
no
okay
how much how much is the money how much
money you get i
it's close to 200
210 after
taxes and everything okay uh what are
you doing for work right now
right now i'm putting myself through a
two-year program at a community college
i'm a single dad and i'm working
part-time on
minimum wage okay do you have any debt
uh just eight thousand on my car
okay and no credit card debt
how much money do you have to your name
and savings
uh
about
about three months worth of
living
okay like three lanes four grand well
when is the settlement coming through
when does this hit your bank account
well it comes in steps and i'll be
getting my first soon at around
and then over the next few years broken
into two more payments okay
well the fact that you called in makes
me think that you want to make sure you
use this money wisely and if you're not
careful this this money could disappear
with a blink and you alluded to that
earlier
yes so if i'm you when this check clears
that first one i'm paying off the debt
and i'm staying out of debt we're never
touching debt again and you can leave
that money in there in savings i might
bump that up to six months for you being
a single dad and we got to get you away
from this minimum wage job i think you
can do better in this market right now
even while you're going to community
college and ken's got a lot of resources
on his website to help you in that arena
but we have got to make sure we use this
money wisely beyond that uh if you don't
have a home right now that might be a
down payment fund if you could pay cash
for something that's even better but
you're in sacramento so that's a pipe
dream but maybe eventually this becomes
a down payment for a house and uh we
invest some of this and we start to
really make a plan for what life looks
like as a single dad taking care of our
kids and leaving legacy yeah barry uh
you don't need to live off of any of
this do exactly what george said the
baby steps hang on we're gonna give you
a couple of resources one total money
makeover
two i'm going to give you the
get clear career assessment i want you
to take a 20-minute assessment really
give you some direction into what could
be some great work for you good money
and a whole lot of meaning as well so
hang on we'll give you both of those
resources because i want you making
really good money now that you've got a
good head start with this settlement
thank you so much for the call this is
the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
so
[Music]
the ramsay show continues thrilled to
have you america i'm ken coleman joined
by george campbell
you need to find out for yourself why
blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings you
get free samples free shipping and with
the new promos they run every month
you'll save even more if you use the
promo code ramsay you get the best deal
today's question comes from bianna in
ohio brianna says my husband and i are
debt-free except for our five hundred
thousand dollar mortgage my husband
earns 120 000 a year and i am a
stay-at-home mom my question is do i go
back to school for nursing in hopes to
make a better living and to help
contribute doing so would create school
debt of fifty thousand dollars we would
pay it off in two years then we would be
able to contribute to retirement and pay
off our mortgage or do i just go back to
the workforce at entry level making
decent money but never really being able
to further my career since i do not have
an education
[Music]
very complex question well but we've got
some logic that's kind of running into
itself yeah so the question brianna is
is do i go back to work because i want
to help make more money okay for for
contributing is the word you used
but
getting fifty thousand dollars in debt
paying for two years on that fifty
thousand dollars in debt
to help contribute is backwards so let's
go to option two because it's option two
but you've got a false narrative in
option two option two is or do i just go
back to the workforce at entry level
making decent money but never really
being able to further my career so the
idea of you going in back to work does
not have to be entry level per se
you don't know that
but if you were to go in entry level the
very definition of entry level is i'm
just on the bottom rung which means
there's opportunity to climb and you can
do that take project management work
right we've gotta you know if you're
organized and you love details and i
have no idea if she is or not but you
begin to go i could be an office manager
you know i could do some basic
accounting if i'm good with numbers you
know a lot of jobs you can get in and
make really good hourly
money and it's not minimum wage and
there's an opportunity for you to grow
because here's what's going to happen
as you get into that you can save money
brianna
towards the nursing degree if nursing is
something you want to do so go get the
day job if nursing is the dream job
let's go get a day job let's contribute
to paying off the mortgage or whatever
and as you're doing so you save some
towards nursing and eventually you fund
the nursing degree but it's not going
into debt um that's not going to help
contribute anything other than stress
and frustration yeah a few things i'll
add to that i'm seeing
a 500 000 mortgage and 120 120 grand a
year my guess is this mortgage is eating
up a large percentage of their income i
think they may have too much house yeah
i agree and so you might need to look
into do we need to get a different
housing situation in order to cash flow
my education if that's the path you
decide to go the other piece i want to
hit on here ken is
to help contribute as if she's not
contributing
at home by being a stay-at-home mom
there's an immense value there
absolutely and so i don't want you to i
think what's happening here she's
feeling like well i'm not contributing
to this family so i need to go out there
and do work yeah that's not the case
yeah and so if if he's making 120 grand
we can figure out a way to make this
money work for us but it's going to
entail getting out of debt staying out
of debt and maybe looking at if we have
we bit off more than we can chew with
this mortgage but either way we're not
going into debt for education and
really decide if nursing is really the
path or if there's something else but to
decide well is either entry level or
nursing those are the only two options
that's a false narrative that's not true
wow appreciate the question let's go
back to the phones valdosta georgia is
where gregory joins us gregory how can
we help
hey um
so i'm 19 and i'm just like starting my
life out because i've been in community
college for like a year now
and i'm gonna make a big move and i'm
trying to decide
on how would y'all start off in my
position
what's the big move
well i'm moving to another town because
right now i'm living with my own family
and i'm gonna move in
with my other family so i'll get on my
feet and in a better town and a better
environment okay
uh why is it a better town better
environment describe that
um
i've seen
i've seen since like
it's a bigger town like i think the cost
of living
is a little higher right but um
also is like money what it's a good
money flow more more professional
options
um
right now i'm studying for automotive
technician
and i'm on a one-year diploma right now
looking to get certified okay
so
i was wondering
should i like i'm just kind of debating
because i'm like
because right now i'm in the academic
portion of college
and i didn't want to stress myself out
so i didn't get a job
so i've been home
okay so you're so you're one year in a
community college um and and so is is
what you're doing in the community
college is that getting you that uh
mechanical
certification or however you would
phrase that
yeah yeah it's getting my certification
in that
only reason i'm getting certified
because i can go out there and just work
on cars on the street and stuff and yeah
that was nice that's my question so
let's just press pause on the community
college for a second
you know your way around an engine i'm
guessing yes
yes sir
what would keep you uh from getting a
job with a local mechanic in this new
town you're moving
to um
i just wanted to be certified so i'll
have like a bigger gain i understand
that but that's not the question i asked
what would keep you from getting hired
even if it's entry-level mechanic in
this new town
anything
not really meaning you got the chops you
could go in an interview if you had an
interview
you feel like you got the chops the
ability to go in and do basic mechanic
work regardless of the certification
that's what i'm asking do you believe
that's true
yes sir yeah interesting
well how soon are you making the move to
the town the new town
well
then next semester because i can
transfer colleges because they have the
same campus on in the other town
so um
that starts may the 16th
so it's pretty soon
okay
i'm just now finishing up
on my
no no you're good so in may you're gonna
move and uh how much left of the
uh
community college work to get the
certification to be able to get paid
more as a mechanic how much is that of
of that is left
uh right now with the academics i only
have an essay then
may the 16th i start the afternoon
classes for my mechanics so what i was
going to do is going to pick up a job
yeah but
um and just go in the afternoon to those
classes right so i was trying to figure
out
what would you do
oh sorry no i'm just going with that
what would you do
in my position like trying to
trying to save money because i've been
working ever since i was 16 i've worked
at a peanut mill and i used to make like
bring home maybe 800 a week seasonally
and um i used to just help my parents
with bills because i i just feel like i
just felt at that time i had to
well so what's your question gregory it
sounds like we make this move we get a
part-time job we start the new semester
at the new community college we cashflow
the whole thing
and life's great
where what's holding you back yeah i get
a job i don't think this is that intense
that that community college go go get
some part-time work
and then get done with the certification
as soon as possible and get hired as a
mechanic you enjoy the work you're good
at the work let's go
yes sir now george tell him how to save
money once he's making full-time money
well do you have any debt gregory
currently
no i don't have any debt i'm perfectly
clean clean slate okay i don't
you have any money in savings
oh no sir okay so you have no money to
your name except whatever's in your
checking account
i don't even have a checking account
you don't have a bank he's living with
family and going to school but how old
are you're 19 you don't have a bank
account we need to fix that today i'm
going down to local credit union your
local bank and open an account today
i mean where's your paycheck going are
you cashing it at walmart
we got to figure that piece out so i'm
getting banked because that's going to
help you get on your feet get a savings
account and start to make some wise
financial moves stay out of debt and
you'll be okay you're a sharp dude
you'll make some good money being a
mechanic in the trades we love that yeah
if we ain't working we can't save so
part-time job first paycheck that bank
account set up and uh hang on the line
let's uh let's give you total money
makeover it's going to see how to stay
debt-free how to save how to build well
hang on the line this is the randy show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsay show i'm
ken coleman joined by
my colleague george campbell
uh
so george we're talking about life we're
talking about money we're talking about
work relationships and uh saw a headline
cnbc article
college graduates are overestimating the
salaries they'll start at by as much as
50
000
dollars
all right so give you some back story on
this as hiring demands
have continued to increase coming out of
the pandemic very hot job market right
more jobs available
than there are people who are unemployed
so it's just driven up salaries and this
is part of the inflation game right what
people do you understand about inflation
is one of the inflationary measures that
we tend to not think about is when when
target's pain is starting
uh hourly rate of 17 an hour well
they're gonna pass that on to the
consumer uh in the form of the cost of
your lupa or luffa or whatever those
things are thank you for remembering ken
absolutely and uh so uh what we're
seeing now is
obviously average starting salaries even
for college graduates is sneaking up the
class of 2022 george is projected to
make
uh to be a starting salary is projected
to be more than 50 000 however
this is where the reality check needs to
come in
that same group of students 20 22 grads
are expecting to earn twice that amount
in their first job and expect to make
six figures job
so uh we've got a real disconnect there
uh undergraduate students across all
majors and institutions overestimated
their starting salaries by 88
this is a study from the real estate
witch
uh which needs a branding class wow
that's an unfortunate name oh my
goodness and ten years into their
careers these students anticipate making
more than two hundred thousand dollars
well over the average mid-career salary
of 132 000.
wow so george where do you think that's
coming from you you're tied into the
youngsters i think youngsters they have
a pretty high risk tolerance and so
they're looking at college going well
yeah if i go to college you
automatically get a high paying job at
the end of it as soon as you walk the
stage they just come clamoring to give
you a job of six figures and that's not
the case and i'll tell you that be i say
that because i sat down with a bunch of
high schoolers as we were filming our
personal foundations and finance
curriculum personal finance curriculum
and as i interviewed these students i
went so what do you want to do
what kind of job where you want to go to
school how much is going to cost how
much do you think you're going to make
some of them thought it was an
interrogation they ran away in tears
after we were done wow no one has asked
them these questions can including uh
their parents they're not having these
conversations the teachers that's where
these crazy numbers are and so it's all
in their mind of just going well a
hundred thousand dollars
is what mom and dad make so that's what
i'm gonna make when i graduate college
and there was such a disconnect
they went well this is how much i'm
gonna get paid as a physical therapist
whatever the job was it was always
inflated now they may get there over
time but year one you're not going to be
making six figures in most jobs no
listen
this information right here folks is why
it's vitally important for high schools
public private and colleges to teach
financial literacy you know i mean i
mean it's it's so important i'll tell
you what it leads to because they have
no idea it leads to the student loan
crisis we're seeing because students go
well ken i'm happy to take on a hundred
thousand dollars because i'll be able to
pay it off easily that's always the case
and what happens they have 150 000 in
student loans and they're making 42 000
a year and then they feel like they were
lied to and they demand student loan
forgiveness because this is a scam oh
yeah when they really just didn't do
their due diligence they didn't do their
research they didn't have the right
conversations and it's heartbreaking i
don't want this for any student it
really is because here's what here's
where the perfect storm collides
they they've created this mythical
salary and this this mythical financial
uh journey that they're going to be on
and then that doesn't happen and then
they've grown up getting a trophy just
for showing up right use sports and it's
just like so then all of a sudden the
reality hits them and it's no joke
it's not funny it's it's it's
disheartening and disillusioning when
they come out and they feel like
i went and did all this time i got all
this debt i could barely afford the debt
payment and i was supposed to have this
life you talk about rocking somebody's
world while their brains are still
developing well an 18 year old has no
idea what it's like to pay bills to pay
insurance no
and so they walk into their adult life
going hold on i have to make a car
payment and my student loan payment and
my credit card payment and they can't
breathe so you've got to have a reality
check here come on wake up folks wake up
all right ashley is joining us now in
chicago illinois ashley how can we help
oh my word hi guys thanks for taking my
call you bet ashley she's so sure about
you what's happening
that's awesome um george you're my
favorite by the way anyway
hold on a second hold on james can i
take this segment off ashley give me a
second i have to take the dagger out of
ken's heart
it's okay george hannah i'm going to
take a smoke break go ahead
ashley how can we help today
all right so in short my mother-in-law
is trying to buy my husband and i a 500
000 house whoa and
yeah
and um he's an only child works in the
family business is planning to take over
and um we've also been living rent free
in one of their properties uh the last
three years since we've got married so
we've never really had to worry about
you know the normal bills all of that
and so i came from a different
background i'm kind of feeling like
we're being taken care of which is a
good and a bad thing
but i also don't feel like we're adults
uh he thinks we should be taking kind of
taking advantage of this and looking at
it as you know the lord is blessing us
with
so much um and she wants to buy us this
house because we had our first daughter
four months ago
um
congratulations oh yeah that's awesome
thank you is she paying cash for this
house on your behalf is she just gifting
you a paid for 500 000 house
yes exactly all cash
whoa and so i kind of feel like we're
cheating our way through the baby stuff
but i also feel like if we said no to
this i i think i'm looking for
permission
um i'm not really sure i
well george is your favorite
wow you've lost ken that
he's done with you ashley no this is
fascinating no this is a wild scenario i
mean in this case i don't want you to
feel like you're cheating now i don't
want her you know coddling you guys
forever and giving you an allowance
you're grown adults and so i think what
you're wanting is that sense of
independence and agency and going hey i
pay my own bills i'm a grown woman i'm a
mom right which by the way you will
exactly which you will and so i'm
looking at this as they they've left a
legacy they want to bless you with this
and so now if she said hey i'm going to
take out a mortgage in your name and you
pay the bills i'm going
now i do want to know if there's any is
there any agenda here is she saying hey
i'm hands off i don't get to tell you
how to live your life financially i just
want to bless you with this is there any
strings attached
not that i know of um in the past
they've definitely been the more um
you know want to know what's going on in
our life our house was next door to them
before and they want to kind of be in
our business but it's gotten a lot
better the past year
um this house is about 20 minutes
farther from them from where we are now
so we do like that idea that's healthy
but um
the fact that my husband is an only
child
has taken longer to have they spoiled
him
oh yes it sounds like he's had it pretty
good
now we're starting to get he knows it
yeah
well is she still folding his laundry i
mean what level of you know
coddling is happening here oh very
so he's very independent at home um
he cooks for me so i love it
i just wanted to make sure because
sometimes you kind of have those
helicopter parents that can't let go of
their little boy and it's a grown man
now and he's a dad and we have to
separate and so if i'm you i'm taking
this deal i mean this is the deal of a
century and it's gonna catapult you into
baby step seven and the best thing you
can do is take advantage of this by
staying debt-free building unbelievable
wealth leaving a legacy for your kids
and maybe doing the same for them one
day i don't know what that looks like
for you guys but i'm taking this deal
and i think you you may have to grapple
with the emotions of this being handed
to you and feeling like wow with such
privilege but yeah this is what legacy
looks like
and so i'm going to take that as a
blessing and make sure there's no
strings attached and say hey mom you
know in-laws love you guys but
there's no say over what you know you
tell us to do with our money and our
life but we so appreciate you guys this
is the biggest blessing of our life
any advice on how to explain this to
my family who's in a completely opposite
situation well are they going to be
upset when they find out we're moving i
don't think they're going to be upset i
think they're going to wonder how how
are we doing this
[Music]
well you know you're not taking a poll
and so you tell them as news you're not
asking for an opinion here and you move
on with your life you say mom dad i love
you guys we've been blessed with this
and i wanted to let you guys know and
that's it yeah really great congrats on
the little one congrats on this
unbelievable gift it is a blessing i
agree with your husband take it
hey george good stuff good hour thanks
for hanging out i think james and the
entire team uh behind the glass and most
importantly want to thank you america
this is your show it is the ramsay show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rand want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show it's
where we talk about your life your money
your work and your relationships triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the toll free number to jump in
i'm ken coleman he's george campbell and
we are here for you this hour thrilled
that you've joined us triple-a two five
five
two two five george you're ready to go
you ready to help some people always
ready always a good day when it's with
ken coleman oh well i appreciate that i
appreciate that john joins us next in st
louis missouri john how can we help
hey how's it going guys it's good to be
talking to you good to talk to you
so listen i got a new job recently that
i'm really excited about moving to a new
state a huge pay bump and i was going
over the health care plan that they
offer
they offer a core plan and a high
deductible plan with the hsa which is a
plan i currently have at my old company
but the difference is here this company
they fully cover the premiums on both
plans which means you know nothing would
come out my paycheck every month awesome
so i'm you know i'm relatively healthy
you know i'm kind of wondering if i
should go with the core the hsa since
the premiums are covered uh the flip
side of that is that the uh
the company actually contributes about
fourteen hundred dollars a year towards
the hsa so that's also another thing to
consider but i'm just kind of wondering
i will be the better option in my case
so
you're saying do both plans have an hsa
you said there's a core plan
there's the core plan that's like normal
like the like a normal healthcare plan
and then there's the high deductible
plan with the hsa i like that option
yeah so what was keeping you from just
sticking with that
yeah i was just wondering because since
they cover the premiums on both plans
100
would it be better to go with the plan
that has a lower deductible well it
sounds like the the incentive to go with
the high deductible plan is the extra
1400 bucks a year they're thrown into
your hsa
right
okay that's what i was kind of thinking
too but i was kind of wondering if that
would be the smarter choice yeah i mean
if you're saying you're a healthy guy
that's still going to be my choice and
the hsa has some amazing triple tax
advantages and you can also start
investing in your hsa once you hit the
threshold in that account
okay perfect yeah i already have the hsa
my current company and uh you know i
really like it there i was just
wondering since i've never had a company
that pays
100 of the premium so that's kind of a
really cool thing great benefit i love
that but i'm still going with the high
deductible plan and the hsa that's going
to be your best bet you can cover all
your health care expenses through that
hsa begin investing in that it can
actually be a cool tool in retirement at
that point so that's what i'm going with
man congrats it's awesome love it
appreciate the call john you're on your
way let's go to jt who joins us in
houston texas jt how can we help
well ken george very nice to hear from
y'all and really appreciate what all you
all do
thank you sir how can we help
well sir i am starting to look at
starting a family with my wife
and
the
car buying industry right now in texas
has just been absolutely hot
five-year-old explorers are going for
the same as msrp
when they were selling brand new and new
cars right now have 10 to 20 000 on top
of them
if i'm looking for a
paid in cash baby hauler what exactly am
i looking for what do you recommend
all right well
jt you said you're looking to start a
family so that means is is
is your wife pregnant or are we just
getting excited about the trying process
uh birth control is coming out next week
okay and
okay that's enough information for us
yeah yeah we didn't need any more than
that but that does help us so we don't
need a baby hauler right now
what's the urgency
i'm the nerd of the relationship she's
the free spirit okay what are your two
i'm assuming you guys have two cars is
that true
yes sir okay what are you driving
i have a 2020 volkswagen passat that i
just paid off uh yesterday hey
congratulations how about that all right
what is she driving
she has a 2001 f-150 all right here's
the great news about both of those cars
all right if you have one baby and it is
possible to have twins and triplets i
don't want to freak you out
but it's possible
all right but if it's just here a little
bit i know dude relax take a deep breath
get a get a brown paper back jt keep it
close by here's the thing man it's a
good chance it's just gonna be one and
both of those cars fit one car seat all
right i know you can look look at me and
listen to me and go ken's no baby expert
and you'd be right but i do have three
kids and they were all babies and i know
that one car seat will fit in both of
those cars here's the point i'm making
we've got time we got some time we need
to relax you don't need a baby hauler in
fact you already have two baby haulers
you don't have eight kids you don't need
to go buy an astro van i mean what's i
don't i think there's more behind this i
think you're are you nervous about
having a kid
of course he is everybody that wasn't
even understated that would be an
understatement that's really the
underlying problem it's not really a
financial question it's not do i need a
car now he's just going oh gosh oh gosh
how is life going to be different once i
have a kid what does this mean for us
yeah and i think those are fair
questions to ask but take a deep breath
it's gonna be okay do you so do you have
any debt right now jt
you told me you just paid off the car
anything else
only thing we have well actually that's
a story out of itself we sold my wife's
2019 rav4 for two grand more than we
bought it two years ago and then used
the 10 grand and positive equity to pay
off my car right and a good portion of
credit card debt so all that's left is
about
12 000 in credit card debt and we're
done which is going to be in the next
three to four months fantastic okay so
that's i think what's going to give you
the piece is we're going to pay off all
of our credit card debt then we can have
a fully funded emergency fund and start
saving up for a car if necessary i truly
don't think you need one in the next few
years
i think unless you have multiple kids i
mean a baby fits in a passat i never
thought i'd have to say that on air but
it's true yeah now jt i don't want you
to faint with this but if you have twins
you can still put two kids and two car
seats in a passat and an f-150 if it's
got a car
so you'll be okay until you actually
feel the pinch we go oh this car is too
tight we can't get it's just too much
and over that by then you're going to be
able to save up and pay cash for a
bigger car if you need if you need the
minivan if you need the baby hauler as
you called it you'll be able to do that
with cash i would not worry about the
car market just buy the car that you can
afford
jt what got you to this point of being
close to being debt free
is gonna keep you out of debt it's gonna
allow you to save up for any car that
you need i promise
and it's now let me just speak
practically to this if for some reason
you know you're thinking well my passat
or her f-150 isn't gonna do it i'm in
the car market right now for my wife
number one and number two for a teenager
who's about to be driving i'm looking at
cars all the time
uh if we're just calling it a baby
hauler there are plenty plenty of good
deals that you will be able to afford
and pay cash
that are serviceable and they may not be
they won't be brand new and they may not
be a couple years old but they will get
baby and mama and daddy from point a to
point b so appreciate the call jt and
listen um
i didn't know what i was doing when our
kids were born i still don't know what
i'm doing as a dad of teenagers it's
okay you're gonna be okay man you're a
good dude you're responsible and it's
going to be all right
and if you need car buying advice i mean
if you're looking at suvs and minivans
later on
toyota and honda are solid solid
vehicles uh i understand what our
cabinet is what was that other brand
toyota okay they always make fun of me i
say toyota instead of toyota whatever
you said america was going i've never
heard of that car brand george and we
trust you america's tell me about
problems ken than how i pronounce toyota
oh no it's not a problem i just needed
to clarify it you did good
hang in there george it's all good we'll
get there you're the man hey don't move
more of your calls coming right up this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back america you are listening
to the ramsey show a conversation about
your life your money your work your
relationships george campbell
and i can coleman join you to take your
questions triple eight eight two five
five two two five triple a eight two
five
five two two five let's go to new york
city new york mike is there mike how can
we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call i
love the show thank you sir how can we
help you
uh so i graduated school in 2020 with
about forty seven thousand dollars in
student loan debt
and uh over the past eighteen months
i've been paying that down even though
it's been in forbearance
um with everything going on in the news
recently and talks with biden writing
off uh 10k
of student loans it just so happens that
i'm
at about 10 000 left
so i'm just kind of
wondering should i
just keep paying it down or
potentially leave free money from the
government on the table
i'm sorry i'm not laughing at you i'm
laughing at that statement free money
from the government uh a thing that
doesn't exist actually it's always
coming back to you one way or the other
and um i i could be wrong on this and
i'm hoping i'm wrong
um
but uh
i don't see it happening i think it's a
campaign year midterm elections are
coming up and i think this is something
that uh gets dangled out there because
it is uh
it's a winning talking point in that a
lot of people have student loans are
going oh that would be great it'd be
great it'd be great um but i just do not
expect it to happen because quite
frankly student loans are big money
business for the government george yeah
i'm i'm 100 with you ken as i was
laughing at the uh the idea of well in
the news there's been talks
oh a politician talking look at that
that's progress
and so i'm not banking on that and like
ken's saying what's happening here is
approval ratings are low midterms are
coming up we got to make them look good
to get rea so what's happening here is
they dangle the carrot to make people
vote and then they keep kicking the can
down the road and as we've seen the
student loan forgiveness stats are
abysmal
one or two percent of the people that
applied have been forgiven and you've
already done the hard work mike to get
down to ten thousand dollars from 47. so
how many more months is going to take
for you to pay off
it should be done in in august
i'll tell you this much by august there
will not it will not have happened
i'm happy to be wrong like ken said and
uh you will not look back with regret
when you're debt-free and you don't have
a payment in the world you know just be
happy for those that got their ten
thousand paid off if it even ever
happens but i'm not holding my breath
yeah and mike listen you're a good dude
i mean you're a high character guy
that's why you've already gone after it
you know you've already been paying it
down even though they were in
forbearance and uh smart listen
you took out the loan does not make you
evil does not make you bad you're not a
criminal you're not a person of low
character but you signed up for that you
took it out and paint it back and i just
think that you know we've got to
remember this folks that you know you
know
the end of the day i understand why
emotionally if you've been under the
weight of these loans that you're
holding out for it but i wouldn't hold
out for it yeah well people feel like
they've been lied to when it comes to
the entire student loan crisis and
college and the promises at the end of
the day at what point do we go well we
should extend this to credit card debt
and
all kinds of debt and the truth is you
signed up for the debt you got to pay it
back that's just how it works you don't
want to do that don't go into debt no so
uh way to go mike keep paying it off
call us back when you're debt free we
would love to celebrate with you august
is going to be here before you know it
mike really proud of you man keep on
going and it's it's going to be a
challenge that you look at on the other
side of this thing of being free of that
student loan debt you're going to look
back and it's going to it's going to
really build character it's going to
teach you a lot
it's it's going to remind you later on
in life where you have another challenge
that you can do it so there's nothing
but positives by paying this off
uh houston texas is where we go next
marianne is on the line marianne how can
we help
hi my name is miriam and i am calling
another student debt question
uh
basically i have a bachelor's degree um
in a degree that i haven't used i
finished it like over 10 years ago maybe
13 years ago now
it was a communications degree and then
i became a then i was a stay-at-home mom
for a while
and um
i our home is paid off
um so we don't have debt um
but
there have been a couple bumps along the
way as happens in some people's lives
anyway long story short i'm here and
we just had a baby about eight months
ago
but i i have been thinking about going
back to school i had been working as a
teacher i mean i would stay at home but
then i went back to like work as a
teacher part-time at the preschool where
my daughter was at and then i went to
doing that full-time
anyway
um i had been taking pre-requisite
classes in school saying speak directly
into your phone marianne it sounds like
we've got some wind or something there
oh sure
so i had been taking the prerequisite
classes just one at a time
you know while i was working
um
and i finished them i got into a state
school
so the price is right um we saved up the
money we do have the money to pay for
the school outright but i'm like
i did apply for as you know for the
scholarships they had available and i
got you know like four thousand dollars
in scholarships which i was really proud
of and i was like that's great you know
that'll help
um
we have about maybe 40 000 saved my
husband makes about 40 000 a year
um
and
i just i mean there is like they do have
this unsubsidized or they have a
subsidized loan
it's just fifty five hundred dollars hey
marianne let me ask you a question um
what are you getting a degree in i
didn't catch that what are we why are we
going back to getting it oh
i i'm getting a degree in nursing i'm
getting um it's an accelerated 15-month
program for nursing school that way
i just
wanted to be able to increase my income
from being
you know a preschool teacher and i know
i probably could do other things but do
you want to be a nurse
or is this just a i mean well let me let
me ask it differently do you want to be
a nurse because you are a caregiver and
you love the idea of that interaction or
do you want to be a nurse because
benefits are great and the money is much
better than a preschool teacher
i'd say it's a combination of both like
i for a long time
after i had my first kid and even a
little bit before that i was really
interested in like holistic and kind of
like healing and preventative medicine
and that kind of care so as far as being
a caregiver
i have that part down
and so how much money would you have to
how i'm sorry to interrupt how much
money are you gonna have to um
borrow
to pay for this nursing degree because
you don't have the
cash we do have the cash in our savings
so why are you considering a student
loan if you have the cash to pay for it
yeah that's where i'm at i love that
voice sorry well i was just i just
thought like maybe it would be like free
money which you know you guys are the
wrong people what is free money i'm so
confused since when is a student loan
free money
well because there's no interest being
charged on it while i'm in school and
the interest only accrues until six
months after so i figured like hold on
you just told me you have a paid for
house did you guys get out of debt at
some point
sorry
yeah i do have paid for his house okay
never mind i'll hang up i'm embarrassed
i'm not trying to embarrass you i'm
trying to show you i'm trying to show
you the logic of you guys work so hard
to get out of debt so that you don't
have payments anymore and so i don't
want you to move backwards when you guys
have sacrificed you know your sharp
couple you have a great income like
let's just pay cash for this and be done
with that's the reason you saved up
forty thousand dollars not for it to sit
there but for to be put to use yeah
marion don't be embarrassed i can't tell
you how many people in my life would
tell me something like that oh it's free
money because the interest but the
reality is is the minute you get out of
nursing school the interest starts
accruing and now you've got this debt
that you're working to pay off and you
said you wanted to make more money so if
you want to make more money then go
ahead and pay it use some of that
savings get it done it's a 15 month
accelerator program now you hit the
ground running marianne and you're
making really good money and that is
going towards replenishing savings
walking these baby steps out getting
back into that now you're investing
uh this is you don't you've got the
money don't borrow it
don't borrow it it is not a good deal
it's not going to help you out
yeah i did not mean to shame marianne in
that call to make that very clear yeah
well george you can't raise your voice
of people i'm sorry you know how i get
i'm known for my anger and being loud
and aggressive it's great no listen i
think i think that's something a lot of
people tell i bet you she's had people
in her life that have told her that hey
it's free money
why would you use your own money borrow
other people's money opm that's how you
get wealthy ken yeah yeah it's a trap
all right hey good stuff there thank you
for the call marianne don't move more of
your calls coming up this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back america you are joining the
conversation here on the ramsey show
talking about your life your money work
your relationships i'm ken coleman
joined by joined by my colleague george
campbell and we're taking your calls
this hour triple eight eight two five
five two two five
hey when we get together as a team here
at ramsey solutions we're talking about
our mission to change america's toxic
culture in the area of money and work
and relationships and it makes us mad to
see in that money area so many people
trapped by debt or to watch kids sign
away their future for a student loan
uh for folks who work here this isn't a
job it's a mission if that sounds like
something you could get excited about
you got to check out all the exciting
roles at ramsey solutions because we are
looking to hire asap so let's go we need
developers ux designers and writers to
help us build digital products that
actually change people's lives to see
what it's like to do work that matters
with us before you apply follow us on
instagram and facebook by searching
ramsay careers apply for your dream job
at ramseysolutions.com
careers that's ramseysolutions.com
careers all right sioux falls south
dakota is where we go next zachary's
there zachary how can we help
how are you guys doing we are having a
blast what's going on
um i have a question about
how
a roth ira works because i know how dave
says you can invest 6 000
a year
for 40 years at the max
and he said it
like at 12 or something it
grows to like 5.8 million so i was just
wondering like how
i know the rough numbers but how exactly
does it multiply
oh good question how old are you zachary
i'm 29 about to be 30 at the end of july
okay and uh have you been following the
baby steps
um
we're about to start um i'm doing every
dollar trying to work out the kinks with
that i love that app but um
it's uh
it's in the works we are
you have debt right now we're trying to
do it
yeah we have debt we got um there are
there's some old debts there's there's
like one large one that's with a
collection agency that threatened to
they got a judgment on us but nothing
has ever happened with that
um
it's mostly medical bills there's two
small credit cards in there that are
they're like both under a thousand
it was like credit one and capital one
okay well i asked just to find out where
you guys are at in the in your financial
picture and i want you to use your
income because it's your greatest wealth
building tool to become wealthy and it's
hard to do that when you've got payments
in your life and so if you follow our
plan baby step one thousand dollar
starter emergency fund baby step two pay
off all of your consumer debt using the
debt snowball then we never touch debt
again then we focus on the emergency
fund three to six months of expenses in
a savings account then we can talk about
investing
so i say all that to say we're not quite
ready i love your question i'm getting
to that but i want you to know where
that falls in our plan so you don't jump
ahead of yourself right
so yep i'm very familiar okay good so
the roth ira it you know when we talk
about compound interest which is what
you're talking about that works with any
type of investment i know so we talk
about good growth stock mutual funds
inside of your roth ira or roth 401k and
compound growth is fairly simple
it it's when your money makes money
and so if i've got a thousand dollars in
there and i've got a 10 11 12 return
those are not numbers that we made up
out of thin air that is just tracking
the s p 500 the top 500 companies in the
stock market and that's what the numbers
have been over the inception of it back
in the you know the 1930s and so
when you look at that you go okay my
money can make me 10 to 12 in the market
well then that 10 to 12 percent gets
compounded every single year because
that thousand dollars turned into 1100
and now you get twelve percent on the
eleven hundred and that turns into
fifteen hundred which turned to three
thousand so over time your contribution
is a small percentage of the actual
number in that account and so that's
what happens over time
okay so like what happens if uh
someone
just puts money
into the roth ira but does not
use mutual funds does it grow
at all or oh i mean you got to put
something in there you can't just have
an op a shell of an account you got to
actually fund that roth ira fund that
401k with something and so some people
do mutual funds that's what we recommend
you can do an index fund which is
similar you could do
single stocks which i don't recommend
but with single stocks it's going to be
a lot more volatile that's right if i
just invest in tesla and if you've seen
the news tesla's real volatile right now
well i'm freaking out i'm losing sleep
at night but when i invest in a mutual
fund well that one fund has a ton of
different companies and then when you
diversify that and you have four
different types of mutual funds you're
even more diversified which lowers your
risk and so that's why we tell people to
invest in those types of funds
and if you do that you can become a
millionaire but you got to get out of
debt you got to have the savings and
then we can begin investing that 15 of
our income into retirement
thank you for the call zachary next we
go to raleigh north carolina rob is
there rob how can we help
good afternoon gentlemen happy friday
happy friday to you sir what's up
uh so i have an uh interesting question
for you guys i i am uh in baby steps
four five and six with our with our
family great and i know that i know the
position that you all take with respect
to
leasing vehicles
and i'm not gonna try to set any new
precedent today but i do have a question
on the lease idea when it comes to
horses
my wife is
really into horses and so are my kids
when you're in baby step two you don't
get to enjoy that type of thing but now
we're in four five and six
they would like to get a horse or or two
and uh apparently it's become popular
this in today's time to actually lease
a horse so that basically you have the
monthly payments and the upkeep but you
don't have to worry about well i guess
it depends on your contract but you
don't have to worry about
getting rid of it at the end of the day
okay hold on a second all right hold on
hold on i gotta know more because this
might shock you i know nothing about
leasing horses uh
is this like a boat thing where multiple
people are using the same boat multiple
multiple people using the same horse you
get you get larry the horse monday
wednesday friday i mean what's the deal
it is not a time share
it is uh you're actually uh you got all
so you it's only you and your family and
larry nobody else rides larry
that's it so you're just renting a horse
essentially wow
basically yeah okay well why would you
why would you why would you think
the reason i distinguish that from a
vehicle right is because of the vehicle
at the end of the day you can take it to
another you know dealership and you know
they might give you cash for it a horse
is much more difficult to get rid of
yeah you know this is
do you know what happens to poor larry
the horse when we get rid of them it's
awful
i don't think you can say that live i
know i'm not planning to two things
everybody knows just because it's
popular doesn't mean it's not a terrible
idea eating tide pods became popular
doesn't mean we should all start doing
it
no
so leasing a horse is no different a
horrible idea if you can't pay cash for
it you can't afford a horse how much
does it cost to buy a horse
no i don't think the issue is paying
cash for it i think the issue is once
you know if you need to up and leave if
you need to move you can sell the horse
you can't
okay
i mean i guess you could i guess you're
assuming that there are willing buyers
out there you're a willing buyer can i
remind you that you are willing to buy a
horse rob thought he got me there in the
corner do you not think there's other
robs out there who may want a horse yeah
who have little girls that want to ride
a horse i wouldn't plan on it being an
appreciating asset well you got to look
at this thing as a liability it's an
expense this is a hobby but if you guys
are debt-free and you want to pay cash
for a horse and deal with all the
maintenance because this is a dream of
yours i'm okay with that okay
but do not fall for this horse leasing
business it's just awful
i mean rob you're a good guy you're in
baby steps four five and six like you
didn't think we were gonna be cool with
this did you
i didn't but it just seems different
than a vehicle i mean it's just so rough
justification station here you're
looking for any reason to get this horse
at any cost i i got i got a little
comeback rob there was a time in the
world where horses were the only
vehicles
rob quit horsing around let's pay cash
for this there it is folks i was
wondering if you were gonna say that i
was there george campbell for the win
everybody
here to save the day james would have
killed you to pull up a horse sound to
take us out somebody in the booth's got
to be thinking there's a reason they
don't let us use sound effects on the
show oh very good all right hey rob baby
says four five and six does not include
leasing a horse this is the ramsay show
[Music]
welcome back america this is the ramsey
show i'm ken coleman i'm joined in
studio by george kimmel our verse of the
day comes from ecclesiastes 5'3
for a dream comes with much business and
a fool's voice with many words
our quote from coach mike shishesky he
recently retired from duke basketball my
hunger is not for success it is for
excellence because when you attain
excellence success just naturally
follows and that is true
uh one last call there
great job wanting to know if he should
lease a horse and i missed the the
buzzer beater line ken when he asked
should i lease a horse and i should have
said
nay
you should not lease a horse oh yes the
dad jokes i say it's really good wow
george every dull day around here i'll
tell you that much ken yeah i will tell
you had you said that real time i would
have been done you had been under the
desk you would have had to take us a
break that was just so good too many
horse puns too we're having a good time
we are so glad you're with us let's get
back to the phones philadelphia
pennsylvania kitty is there
kitty how can we help
hi george ken how are you today we are
having a little too much fun we're told
i hear it we're horsing around today i
see that yeah
there we go
uh
i so my question for you today is um
and thank you for taking my call sure uh
my husband and i just got done uh fcu a
couple about a month ago
and um
which was uh a blessing because i had
tried to get him to do that for over a
year
um but he finally uh caved in and
actually enjoyed the class and now he's
like on board with me awesome my
question is we took a 401k loan out
um which we know is a big mistake now
and um so we're trying to clear that up
because really that's probably
uh 90 percent of what's left for our
dad here because we're on uh baby step
two
we paid off about 40 000 already
since we started the class
um
so thank you to marketplace on facebook
because that was a big help awesome
selling stuff on there
yes selling stuff on there and just
getting rid of stuff we never use and it
was just actually was fun because we
watched the numbers go down but now
we're stuck with this 401k loan and
not sure what to do so i made some calls
today um about getting a loan to pay off
the 401 hold on hold on kitty
what are we doing here
you're getting a loan to pay off a loan
does that not sound backwards to you
it does sound backwards to me and that's
what we were afraid of is that we just
stick with the 401k loan pay it off
in the five years that you know it's
recommended or
get a loan pay it off now and pay that
loan off within two years
now we've got to focus on behavior here
because right now we're just trying to
solve a problem with another problem
instead of find the solution which is
work our butts off and pay this thing
off with our cash flow with our savings
and then never touch debt again the
heloc is that we're talking about
getting a heloc
yes i believe that's what it is
a home equity
equity
it's the equity in our home
so essentially you're going to use a
credit card to pay off debt to then pay
off the credit card debt
leaving us back at square one
that's what i don't know because i'm not
very good at what equity is in your home
i'm not i'm just telling a home equity
line of credit you're using your home
like a credit card and you're borrowing
against your home you're putting your
home at risk the heloc is not going to
create cash flow it's just debt it's
just putting you further into debt
and so you got to save up we got to pay
cash and uh get this 401k loan paid off
what's the 401k loan what's on there how
much
uh it's like 34.5 okay and what's your
income
uh
150. okay so what's stopping us from
using our income plus more facebook
marketplace selling to get this 401k
loan out of our life
nothing i just we just want to make sure
we
i guess it's the five year mark that's
getting me we know we're not going to be
able to pay it off
i don't understand why you would pay it
off you said earlier that uh it's five
years if you just pay it out of the 401k
uh paid off there versus two years with
the with the the other loan i don't
understand that math
i'm sorry go ahead well you're just
moving one pile to a you know it's one
pile to another pile it just makes no
sense i'm gonna do this pile of rocks to
this side of the yard you feel like you
did something and nothing's happening
here
you you and your husband need to get
down
on a plan here and go okay look what can
we sell we've already we've already seen
great progress by selling things george
is right you make 150 you're gonna pay
the 34 off within a year i
agree okay and that's it there's no
shortcuts here there's no two years no
five years
i think here's the fun question for you
and your husband and i mean this this is
date night what would it take for us to
pay off
that loan in one year what would it take
what would have to be true it's a great
exercise
you know what i mean because even if you
can't get to a year we might find that
we can get there in a year and a half
but what would need to be true that's a
fun exercise that's your homework what's
your take-home pay
nine thousand
dollars
i'll take him um
two four six eight about almost nine
okay so you're talking about three
thousand dollars a month would get this
thing knocked out
can you live off of six thousand dollars
a month
i think we absolutely can this thing's
gone in a year and you'll come celebrate
and do your debt free screen with us
how's that sound i mean that's with no
overtime my husband does work a lot of
yeah let's get some overtime let's do it
in eight months let's give ourselves a
stretch goal yeah kitty we're not even
talking about your prowess on facebook
marketplace what else could you sell
that's what i'm going to do this weekend
let's get to work and let's avoid these
shortcut traps like helocs and
consolidation you got this yeah thank
you for the call kitty come on
uh michael's up next in grand rapids
michigan michael how can we
hello thank you for speaking with me
today you bet what's up
um so i just kind of had a quick
question it was really more i mean money
is definitely part of it but it's really
i think more of a behavioral thing so
for a short context uh me and my wife
are both graduating undergrad here in a
couple weeks um and
um i have secured a post-college job
i've been working
while i've been in college we've been in
college um and
um been paying our bills that way
um but
dude throughout the whole time that we
were in college i haven't gotten her to
be able to work
um
also like
i have been helping her a lot with her
schoolwork along with doing my own
um and i i guess my kind of question is
how can i try to get her i guess bring
her to the light a little bit and feel
like you know so everyone has to do
something you know like i'm to be honest
i'm burnt out we have two children i've
been doing most of the caretaking for
them i've been doing all of my sport
helping her out heavily with hers
working the entire time i have offers to
go to law school next year and i'm i'm
just burnt out i really i'm just tired i
like sometimes i don't know like how to
keep fighting the fight or just accepts
that she's gonna be lazy and just not do
anything okay
so
uh
number one we can't answer this in the
uh a lot of time that we have number two
it's not even a behavior issue with her
it's this is a marriage issue first and
foremost
for you to sit down with a counselor and
i mean i would i would do it soon
and and you've got to share this
in in the healthy
professional space
because there's something going on here
with her
and and and then you are already to a
place of resentment
yeah
and listen resentment will eat you up
it'll eat you alive so
this is a what i would call a five-alarm
marriage fire is what this is
and i'm sitting down with a counselor
it's where i can be honest
but we gotta dig and see what's going on
i will tell you this not knowing your
wife at all
i'd be willing to
guarantee you she's not lazy she's lost
and i tell you that because i think that
you've got to change the way you see
your wife going into counseling i
understand why you think she's lazy but
i don't think she's lazy i think she's
lost
and and i don't know what's causing her
to feel lost in her identity and what's
going on that's what we got to get to
the bottom of and you need help with a
professional counselor to pull that out
of her to identify that you may even
know and i'm not going to put you on the
spot and ask you to do that but
i appreciate the call and i will tell
you this is a cry for help
and i'm glad you called but let me just
tell you uh you need to have some
empathy and compassion towards your wife
as you move into this counseling session
i'm heartbroken for you michael but hang
in there don't you dare quit
george campbell thank you pal fun times
always fun to be with you thanks to our
entire team in the booth appreciate you
all i want to say thank you to america
this is your show this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
do you love a good dave rant want to see
the latest ramsay show videos going
viral check out your favorite moments
from the ramsay show on youtube go watch
and subscribe to the ramsay show channel
on youtube
[Music]
you